major gavi and his troops are going on
duty the Indian soldiers work for Munoz
co the largest UN mission in the world
they are supposed to be securing peace
in the city of Goma and they may use
weapons to do so see at times we find
you know crowd which those who are not
generally against the human but since we
are on area domination patrol we find
them and at times it's a tricky
situation you ever gotten a tricky
situation yourself Oh a couple of times
at the end of 2012 UN soldiers had to
stand by and watch as rebel groups swept
through the area seizing control now the
missions mandate is more robust it is
now allowed to go on the offensive
against rebel groups MONUSCO is trying
to set the image of the neutral observer
of war the Indian UN soldiers are
convinced that they are playing an
important part in building peace and
stability in the region nonetheless the
relationship and cooperation with the
Congolese government is not always easy
over the past 15 years Frank bikini with
the information ministry has seen the UN
soldiers work here go from peacekeeping
to becoming a sort of the state within a
state Lomonaco 80 blue jay contra
dancing roll kill 11 when oscar has had
to take on duties that are really
matters of the states for instance
they've been doing road work that's not
what they are here to do the mission has
to end at some point so that people feel
that the DRC is governed by the
Congolese a DDG parla cornwall a
president joseph kabila has made it no
secret he would like the UN to leave his
country as soon as possible originally
the UN and the government were to work
together to defeat the rebel group FDLR
the current dispute escalated at the
beginning of the year when kabila wanted
to deploy two generals who allegedly
where party to war crimes the head of
monusco martin kobler cancelled the
partnership but he refuses to call the
current situation a crisis hiding
something we did have small differences
of opinion with the government we are
now reducing our troops by 2000 and the
government would like us to reduce even
more but we are seeing the security
situation in the country's whole East
deteriorate so we have to consider this
carefully follows with us for details or
fetish proof those suffering most from
the dispute are the Congolese people
more than 3 million of them have already
fled their homes many are furious about
the government's failure but also with
the UN mission yes you did have some
times but I don't think it's it's
necessary to keep that min como anymore
they brought us the opportunity to get
jobs unfortunately that they don't do
their job properly because the mission
is to bring peace in congo jus bout to
be go to 10 even with the monusco
soldiers here people are still dying
there's no difference whether they stay
or go vanessa minnillo berkey despite
the criticism against the UN mission in
the country most Congolese are convinced
that a restoral of all UN troops which
deteriorate
the situation too many rebel groups are
still active in the country that is
almost seven times the size of Germany
and the government is still not able to
handle the issue